I heard do you actually met your husband
on the set of Beetle Juice I did yeah he
was a production designer designed all
those wild sets and and they actually
redid the whole house on the same Hill
in Vermont for this second for the
second one um but he yeah he was talking
to me every day it was like high school
he just talking to me every day like by
our lockers and then he never asked me
out and then he went on to prep the
stuff in in h Vermont and I'm grousing
to Tim Burton about how the production
design never asked me and I said let me
see what I can do and I got there first
day of shooting there bows off to the
side B wel is his name it comes our um
you like to go to the art Department's
going to swap meat you want to come with
us wow like even been forced really
reeling you in yeah I guess but Tim was
right he made it happen I love that you
got set up this is um actually for some
reason tracks for me but like as a gift
a wedding gift he gave you a tour of the
Vatican Tim did yeah a private no
private okay I'm just like that is the
most random wedding gift I've ever heard
of
somebody had given it to him I don't
know it's a very inside kind of deal
what was we okay a priest took us around
he got yelled at at one point I wish I
spoke aali but he was definitely getting
yelled at by another priest because we
were in the Pope's closet like looking
at garments it was crazy we were in the
the elevator that he takes down to St
Peter's Basilica to do Mass we were in
this lovely little um uh uh like a tiny
Museum where all the gifts to the
Vatican from every country in the from
every country leader in the world
gifts that had been sent to the Vatican
since the beginning of the and this
priest is letting us open cases and
pretending to put a crown inside Bose's
backpack taking pictures I wish I had
those pictures with me just crazy you
don't have these pictures somewhere I do
oh man that's amazing yeah but what a
yeah it was beautiful gift it's such a
random GI I'm very memorable I'll give
them that that you were rumaging around
the Pope's closet as one does that's
like when you're like I to say this out
loud going to like real estate or
something and you're like oh to go like
walk just open houses and you're just
going to peek around a little bit
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home